this workshop on behalf of all the other
organizers of the very nose Indians and
Sebastian Koch I think I mean like
welcome you all to this workshop on
hierarchies extended formulations and
mitnick's analytic techniques this it's
always seems like an opportune moment
but have this workshop but this
especially seems like a very opportune
electronics workshop the hierarchies and
it extent formations have been fairly
old ideas and it has been constant
development of them but for the last
five six years has been a ton of work
flurry of work and lower bounds of
extent formation starting with the way
through work on the TSP politic lower
bounds and hierarchies especially SDP
hierarchies are now making their way to
all sorts of alien machine learning
complexity so as proves a sort of even
as a new way to think about a lot of
things and finally the other theme in
this workshop has been what the future
which is actually probably the
hyperbolic programming a real stable
polynomials which are still fairly
beginning to understand and so the
session they sort of have brought theme
of Excel form little upper bounds lower
bounds hierarchies upper bounds lower
bounds and polynomials but the talks are
a little bit mixed up so this is an open
problem session
and serve a constructive yeah thank you
very much thanks very much for the
invitation and for the opportunity to
open this nice workshop with this
overview on extended formulations and on
the constructive side so the organizers
decided to start with the positive side
this not with impossibility results but
it's seeing it at least a little bit of
what can be done and I decided to well
to talk to try to talk depending on what
time permits on these six different ways
how to construct extended formulations
so one of the most classic ones is
junked of programming I go into this and
present an example dynamic programming
or extended formulations that we
assemble somehow the structure of a
given dynamic programming algorithm is a
very big tool to come up with extended
formulations then I will talk about
something that is not so well known
branched polyhedral systems this is a
kind of concept that generalizes both
disjunctive and dynamic programming
based approaches that we came up a few
years ago with the doctoral student of
mine andreas Lewis and then I will talk
about another classical methods dual
ization this was applied very
successfully by Martin in the late 80s
and came up with excel formulations for
the spanning tree poly tope for example
I will talk a little bit about this and
present some later results some more
recent results that have been obtained
in the area of this method and then I
would like to talk about spend a few
more minutes on what I call redundant
information so this is a more
combinatorial way of constructing
extended formulations I would like to
talk about some recent work there as
well and
depending on how much time we will have
in the end I will also talk about rather
specific but as I find nevertheless
rather beautiful method which is based
on some geometrical reflections it's not
apparently not applicable in too many
cases but what it what it yields at
least is nice nice pictures and that
might be a nice way to end the talk so
so we will see how far we get but before
going to these six five or six different
methods how to construct extended
formulations let's briefly introduce a
bit into the concept it I think the
right occasion this first talk of this
week so what is it all about it's about
polyhedral combinatorics so what do we
want to do we want to optimize over
usually in combinatorial optimization
over a finite set a linear function and
the way out is well we represent the
feasible solutions this finite set at
some points in Euclidean space and take
the convex hull because this is more
applicable to two algorithms we can
hopefully represent the convex hull with
fewer data then by just listing all
these points and well if we do so we can
apply a lot of nice theory and
algorithms so of course everything
relies on this trivial fact that
maximizing a linear function over a set
is the same as maximizing it over a
convex the convex hull as the convex
hull we saw on the previous slide and we
can apply our kind of structural results
we know first of all that you can always
do what I did on this previous slide you
can always describe the convex hull by
some finitely many inequalities not too
deep a result and not too new either and
what can you do if you have such an
inequality description so description in
terms of a polyhedral set well you can
apply for example LP duality and this is
already with all not being too deep
either it really gives some structure
insight in many many situations also for
the combinatorial problem so this is at
the heart of what is known as polyhedral
combinatoric for the for the nice part
of the world of combinatorial
optimization and then of course we have
LP algorithms to solve problems like
this and we have efficient algorithms in
theory efficient algorithms and
Octus we even have some errands which
are efficient in both in both balls so
the setup makes a lot of sense and this
is why it was very successfully
investigated over the last decades now
in many situations as you know it's very
difficult to find a system of linear
inequalities describing the convex hull
we have very good reason to believe that
in many cases we cannot even come up
with a decently described set many
situations where we can come up the set
is horribly complicated might be very
very large so you might be interested in
we're relaxing this requirement that you
describe the convex hull well by its
inherent geometric structure requiring
that you need one inequality for every
facet of your of your convex hull it
cannot do against it and you might think
well can I do a little bit more general
and of course we can do and what we can
do is we can formulate an extension or
an extended formulation what is this
well this is just a higher dimensional
polyhedron like this one along with a
linear map I call it a projection that
maps this higher dimensional polyhedron
to the polyhedron of interest and such a
thing I would call an extension of the
red Polito P so Q this poly tope would
be an extension together with a
projection map and what would be an
extended formulation that would be a
concrete description of this extension
poly tope here so a system of linear
equations inequalities inequalities
maybe and why what what are we
interested in well we are interested in
of course in representing our red set by
as few as many inequalities so the
measure that we have for the quality of
such an extension would be the number of
inequalities we need to describe this
set and this is just the number of
facets of this set so the size of an
extension is just the number of facets
of the extension polytope and the
extension complexity of this poly tope e
is the smallest size of any extension
and usually we abbreviate it by X C of P
for extension complexity of P well it
all this makes makes sense because well
whatever you want to do with linear
programming techniques on this poly tope
you can do with that poly tope if you
have it at hand right you can apply
linear programming duality you can solve
the problems that you would like to
solve so that the optimization problems
so having an extension is as good as
having the description in the original
space so it makes sense to do follow
this concept and let's see whether we
can well I go back once more whether we
can come up with something that is more
impressive than this so if you count it
you see that we had eight facets in the
red for the red polytope and I think six
facets for the for the for the extension
so we spared two facets not too many not
too interesting let's see whether we can
come up with more interesting examples
and one of the nicest examples and most
simple to explain to me is this one due
to Bob Carr and Konya what it's for
describing what we call the parity
polytope so the convex hull of the zero
one vectors of length n with an even
number yes an even number of ones so the
convex hull of the even zero one vectors
you can rather easily describe by
cutting off every odd vertex of the
hypercube doing this you need two to the
N minus 1 inequalities and here's a very
very small extension of size only 4n
minus 4 so a linear size extension and
it works like this you represent the
blue 0 1 vectors down here by paths st
paths in this network and whenever you
encounter a one you just switch the
layer and because I place s and T in the
same row with this only works for the e
for the even number of numbers of ones
so obviously every even zero one vector
can represent it this way there's
another one like this one
and obviously we can describe the past
there's tea paths in this network easily
by just by flow constraints so how many
floor how many non negativity
constraints do we have well as many as
we have arcs here and this is 4 and
minus 4 if you can't and so let's
briefly think about the projection what
would be the projection that map's this
path polytope to the to the parity
polytope well let's say how do we obtain
this coordinate well we just sum up the
two variables corresponding to this
crossing arcs right so this is obviously
a projection that here's the parity
polytope so a very simple very easy
example bring you down from a
description of size 2 to the N minus 1
to a linear size description of size 4
and minus 4 still not too many people
are interested in optimizing over the
parity polytopes air is also very easy
algorithm to optimize over them but it's
a nice example of demonstrating the
power of projections at the side remark
you you know you may have encountered
the power of these projections in in a
reverse way and in in when you look at
for your Motzkin elimination if you try
to compute let's say the the convex hull
of a given point set you know that
during the process of for your Muscat
divination in between you might have
your data set explode and what we do
here what we try to do here in this
extended formulation is just to go the
way to exploit this apparently horrible
phenomena
it's a horrible for not phenomenon for
free muskie lumination but maybe we can
exploit backwards this horrible
phenomenon in in in our favor and this
is what we do with the extended
formulations we start with a horrible
thing this parity polytope exploded
polytope so to speak and we represent it
by very harmless polytope which if you
apply for the Motzkin elimination in the
wrong to it ends up with this horrible
thing right so this is we try to turn
this horrible phenomenon into our favor
so this is not too interesting maybe
maybe more interesting is another very
nice and classical extended formulation
that is not not very well known but it's
a good opportunity to present it to you
and it's for the completion times
polytope so
well this polytope you are given n jobs
with processing times P 1 up to PN you
see the jobs numbered from 1 to 5 here
and you search for a schedule this is
just a permutation we have a single
machine of these jobs like this first we
process drop for than 1 then 5 and 2
then 3 for example and for each drop you
are interested in its completion time so
for example the fifth job has a
completion time which is the sum of
these three processing times here and
you look at the completion time vector
for a specific schedule and now you
search for a best schedule with respect
maybe to some weights on the under jobs
so what you are interested in is you are
interested in the convex hull of these
completion time vectors you noted by PCT
p1 up to PN here and it's well known due
to care on how to describe this polytop
you can describe it basically by these
inequalities it's not too important to
decode what is written here it's only
important to see that for every subset
of jobs you have one inequality so again
2 to the N inequalities and here is a
very nice extended formulation which is
due to we'll see it's unpublished he
mentioned it I think in a talk at night
and P some 30 years ago and well the
extension is just a 0 1 cube a 0 1 cube
of dimension n choose 2 and what other
variables associate with this space
where the 0 1 cubes lives in meant to
meant 2d in code you have variables
let's say Y IJ and Y IJ is just meant to
encode whether dropped I is done before
job J right now if you really want to
look at these feasible Y vectors that
could arrive this way you end up with a
horrible poly tope again you end up with
a linear ordering poly tope which you
cannot describe so the variables are
only intended to mean this and the nice
thing is if you project the cube with a
correct rejection it's written down here
and it's easy to come up with after you
know what the variables are supposed to
mean if you project the cube recording
this projection then you find that those
vertices which do not belong to the to
the to the to the linear ordering
polytope their fall into the the
completion time for the top so you
really get a very simple extended
formulation just the cube 0 1 cube with
an appropriate projection so what you
see here is that this completion time
polytope is a sonnet oh so it's a linear
image of of a regular cube so this is
well known for the parameter iran right
the parameter Hedra parameter he'd run
is a special case with this equal
processing times equal to 1 and so it's
a very nice observation due to hoody and
actually the proof of this just reflects
this smith rule that you apply in order
to solve the problem so it's very nice
extended formulation which is
unfortunately unpublished but now you
know that it there okay this is two
rather ad hoc examples and now let's
become a little bit more systematic and
look at the different methods how to
construct extended formation let's start
with item two so disjunctive programming
so this is a very very simple concept
it's just this suppose you have five
polytopes like these five dark blue
polytopes and you are interested in the
convex hull of the union of them so the
lighter blue object here then Bala
observed already in the 70s that it's
pretty easy to come up with inequality
description of an extended formulation
for this convex hull the size of this
extended formulation by josh came up
with is just the sum of the sizes of the
descriptions of the individual polytopes
you feed into the construction very easy
construction so basically just you for
every poly tope here you introduce a
separate set of variables you write down
the inequality system describing the
polytope in its own set of variables you
add another Home Organization variable
and then you write on everything and you
link to Home Organization variables by
requiring that there's some equals one
so you get an extended formulation which
ties
many inequalities as you see in all the
descriptions of the five poly tope so
the sum of the extension complexities it
also works if you have just an extension
of this poly tope it doesn't need to be
a complete description in this in the
original space so but this is very very
useful to come up with extended
formulations in special situations and
despite the construction being very very
simple and very easy to to establish
that it works it can be used very
fruitfully and here's one example I'd
like to show to you it's from some work
we did together with dog Oliver ties
from I saw from the distance over there
and cost a parka which who maybe it's
here as well some years ago and it's
about describing the polytope that is
associated with the mixings in a
complete graph with a prescribed number
L of edges and here let me briefly
explain how how this destructive
programming setting is exploited here so
we are interested in the metrics of size
L in the complete graph so this is the
polytope associated with the matrix of
size L and of course we know from
Edmunds work that we can describe the
matching polytope are these blossom
inequalities again exponentially many
exponentially many in the number of
nodes and if we just add the cardinality
restriction that's fine so can can be
done so how can we do better
well here's a strategy we cover the set
of metrics of size L with a few with
some subsets of these metrics of size L
then for each of the subsets we find a
small extended permutation and then we
just do the disjunctive approach takes a
convex union of the of the convex the
convex hull of the of the Union so what
is the subproblems well the subproblems
is the set of metrics that we call
colorful what does this mean suppose we
spend two L colors to the notes in some
way like this here we have I think six
colors spent so L of three in the
example six colors spent arbitrarily two
to the nodes and now we call a matching
colorful if it uses exactly one color
from each color
glass so this would be a colorful
matching this would be a colorful
matching actually I did not bring in one
colorful matching but you can imagine
what is in long colorful matching so
this is what is the colorful matching
and the nice thing is another colorful
matching no oh I brought it oh here is a
non colorful matching so you know you
very well understand the concept of it
sorry there is to read there is to read
so and yeah and there's another another
reason for not being colorful is that
yellow is missing we have 2 L colors and
a matching is colorful if exactly one
node out of each color class is used so
every color class is used in no color
class is used twice and you have you see
the obstruction in two different places
here
okay now the nice thing is that if you
want to describe the polytope for a
given coloring the polytope of the
colorful matchings you can do it in the
same way as Edmonds did but you only
need a blossom inequality for each odd
subset of color classes so let's look at
it pictorially so first of all you have
the restriction that you are not allowed
to have an edge inside one color class
this is the first set of equations then
you are through the degree constraint
out of each color class
there must be exactly one edge leaving
that's the degree constraint for the
formulated for the color classes and
then you have these blossom inequalities
and now we have for each odd subset of
color classes we have one blossom
inequality what too hard to prove that
this works and this describes exactly
the set of colourful metrics for this
particular coloring and of course now
here you only have two to the 2l well
roughly exponentially in L many
inequalities rather than exponentially
in in the size of the graph so you save
something as long as L is small and we
would choose L logarithmically in the
end so it's polynomial time now this was
the first thing but now we have to
ensure that we come up with only few
colorings such that every matching with
alleges is colorful with respect to at
least one of the colorings and this is
well known as the problem of finding or
using n K in our case n 2 L perfect hash
function family so in our setting a set
of colorings with two other colors is a
perfect hash function family if it does
what we want so every well it does even
a little bit more every subset of 2l
notes is color for with respect to at
least one coloring coloring if we come
up with a set of colorings that satisfy
this then certainly we are done with
with our with all our metrics and
fortunately so this explains just the
concept let's go through that
fortunately there are very small sets of
n K in our case in 2l perfect hash
function families namely of that size 2
to 0 of k k is in our case 2 L times log
n n is n the number of nodes the size of
the ground set and this is due to a lawn
yesterday this week from 20 years ago so
this is meant to indicate where the lock
n factor factor comes in naturally I
just browse through it briefly then you
maybe get an idea with the lock and
comes who but I don't want to spend more
than 10 seconds on this so it's just if
it so this is 8 the ground set of size 8
now if you arrange the ground set in
this way and we do it for K equals 2 we
easily come up with the perfect hash
from a family function of size 3 this is
the first family the first the first
function the first coloring the second
coloring and the third corresponding to
the suite of the pairs three sets of
opposite three pairs of opposite facets
of the cube so this is where how the
lock comes into play very naturally okay
so now we have this and let's wrap it up
so for a particular number L we see that
we can write down our polytop as as many
it's a convex hull of as many colorful
matching polytopes each
kind of formatting polytope can be
described by that many inequalities so
this is the blossom inequalities on the
color classes and this is the remaining
stuff non-negativity on the on the edges
roughly so if we multiply everything
we've come up with an extended
formulation of size 2 to the o L n
Square log N and now if we choose L to
be the logarithm of n we see that this
is a polynomial number so we get a
polynomial size extended formulation of
the L is the lock end matching polytope
and this is kind of a bit surprising
because we know from Thomas nice work
that for the polytope associated with
all the metrics we cannot hope for
something like this right so the
extension of exit is bounded
exponentially from from below in fact at
that point in time when we did this
viscose giant with Dirk this was
interesting because at the same time we
could prove that there is no polynomial
size symmetric extended formulation for
this polytope so this result showed that
there is situations where it really
makes it difference where you whether
you impose symmetry requirement on the
extended formulation or not so that was
a reason why we thought about lock n
matrix at that point in time today it
was just to in order to demonstrate to
you the power of disjunction how do you
can use these junctions to come up with
interesting extended from elections now
let's go to the third point dynamic
programming well than any programming
what is dynamic programming it's very
broad topic so in in our setting it's
it's roughly the dynamic programming are
the dynamic programming algorithms I
would like to consider is algorithms
that you can formulate as finding a
shortest or longest path in an acyclic
directed Network it might be a hyper
graph this network we will talk about
hyper graphs briefly in a minute but
just in just dynamic programming
algorithms that you can formulate in in
this setting like for example for the
knapsack problem or whatever whatever
you know we will have a different
example on the next slides so here is
the example I would like to talk about
it's about we talked about metrics of
size L so far now we talk about cycles
of size L in the complete graph and try
to describe the polytope associated with
the cycles of size L and let's see
whether we can do for l equals log n
something similar as we did for the
metrics and we can and here's how it
goes again we work with colorings now we
work with colorings with with L colors
again we see six colors now L is 600 I
think I call it k now i think i think we
speak about cycles of size k so the
length of the cycle is 6 in these
examples and look at the specific
coloring of the nodes again and call
again a cycle colorful if it visits
every color class exactly once so this
is a special type of cycles of length K
I think Noel L so the length of the
cycle should be L 1 for this coloring
some of the L cycles are colorful now
how can we describe for a specific
coloring the polytope associated with
the colorful cycles we do it this way
first of all there is another colorful
cycle and here's how we do how we
describe for a specific coloring the
polytope associated with the colorful
cycles first of all we enumerate why are
disjunctive programming over every node
that might be that we might fix to be in
the cycle we consider so let's only
consider in this explanations those
colorful cycles that use this specific
red node a and then we enumerate over
all the end notes and do this Junction
okay we get another factor of n this way
but let's just look at the colorful
cycles that use this node a so how can
we describe them well we can describe
them or we can identify them with the a1
a2 paths in an extended network what are
the nodes in this extended networks the
nodes are pairs of original nodes in the
graph like this G and subsets of the
colors
I just enumerate over I well first of
all I describe all the colorful cycles
that use node a then I describe all the
colorful cycles that news node what is
this
I okay and this is only n notes there's
only n notes this is another factor of n
okay we represent these colorful cycles
that use node a as paths in this
extended network that I describe path
from this artificial node a1 to this
artificial node a to what is in one
artificial node so and the the true
nodes they are composed of there are
pairs of original nodes and subsets of
colors and we have an arc connecting
let's say this node to this node in this
network why because these two color sets
are almost the same except for this
color set additionally has the color of
this note that the rule how we define
arcs in this network and then you see
that in this network you find this cycle
as this path not only at this path also
as this path this is just the reverse
cycle of course but I don't care but all
the cycles you find is in fact two paths
in the network right and of course the
paths in this network we can again
describe a means of just flow
conservation constraints there is
another cycle with another path in the
reverse path once you have the digsy
code to produce these figures it's fun
to produce a few more and no it's only
worth to produce a Jacuzzi code if you
produce a few more pictures it's not
really worth it so that's a construction
and this is why later the talk you will
only see hundred hand-drawn figures okay
but for the time being we are still in
the the good old days used exist of okay
so this is how we represent the cycles
and well what is the projection it's
easy to imagine right what is the
how we do we obtain this edge as a
project of the variable how can
represent the variable associated with
this edge in terms of variables
associated with the flows or paths in
this network well it's just the sum of
the variables that corresponds to and in
any situation
to these two nodes right so this is a
projection and so what we see is that
our pls of the polytope associated with
the cycles of length L is the convex
hull of that many colorful cycle
polytopes with prescribed nodes so this
is the additional factor n here and 2 to
the o L times log n again comes from
this perfect egg hash function
constructions due to a long history and
slick and we saw this is what we saw in
the previous slide that each of these
colorful cycle polytope with a
prescribed node has an extended
formulation by means of this directed
network of that size so and here's where
dynamic programming came into play so
this network that displayed to you is
the network that is behind the dynamic
programming algorithm to to find let's
say short shortest a cheapest cycle of
length L well in this situation a tree
pused colorful cycle with a prescribed
node of length L that you would do by
dynamic programming the dynamic
programming algorithm that is just
finding a shortest path or a cheapest
path in this directed Network that it
displayed to you yeah so this is how you
trivially more or less if you have the
algorithm trivially translate the
algorithm into an extended formulation
so I didn't present the algorithm to you
but now you know the network and the
algorithm is just for this path in in
this basically directed Network now if
you again put everything together you
find that the extension complexity of
pls of the cycle poly the length L cycle
polytope is bounded from above by 2 to 0
L times n to the 3 log N
and again if you choose L equals log n
you see that this is polynomial and
again we know this is slightly
surprising because we know that for the
polytope involving all cycles or maybe
the newtonian cycles whatever you like
the extension complexity is bounded from
below exponentially again or some
exponentially certainly not it's not
polynomial this is this breakthrough
paper but if you limas our diversity
very popular it also was mentioned in
the in the introduction to the entire
workshop ok so this is an example of how
you can translate dynamic programming
algorithms now in some situations to
dynamic programming algorithms they do
not work with simple directed graphs but
with directed hyper graphs and also for
this situation you can deal with this
situation at least in some special cases
and this was worked out by martin Rawdon
and kampl in 1990 so if you have a
direct network a directed type on
network that satisfies a very crucial
that satisfy a very crucial condition
then the flow net the floor cultivation
constraints just describes the convex
hull of the hyper paths in that network
and what is the crucial condition the
crucial condition is this so suppose you
have a hyper edge with a single tail V
and this 3 node head set of this hyper
arc then the crucial condition is that
those nodes that you can read from w3
must be different from those that you
can reach from w2 so you're not allowed
to have a hyper hyper graph that which
we rejoin paths if you allow for that
you readily run into problems that by
which you can into we are into problems
which you can model stable set problems
and so on so if you have this additional
condition for all the hyper arcs then
you can come up with a similar extended
formulation but also only in this city
you can really model your problem by
finding a path in this hyper hyper graph
right so if the dynamic programming
algorithm works like this then you can
translate directly okay now let's see
let's only very briefly mention what
this branch polyhedrus systems are I
would not explain them to you but it's
it's a way to generalize to have a
common generalization of both this
dynamic programming and this disjunctive
approach and well the set up is just
like this you have again a governing
directed graph structure an acyclic
directed graph with a single source and
now you have associated with every
non-terminal node you have associated a
polytope in the space associated with
its out neighbors let's say you have
associated is 0-1 polytope with a with
every with every vertex you have
associated this is one party top that
lives in the space that is indexed by
its out neighbors and if you have this
this is for node V this saps the set of
subsets of out neighbors that make the
vertices of the polytope that is
associated with this node and now if you
again have a special condition that's
similar from the condition that we had
on the previous slide that well in this
graph here if you is an out neighbor of
V and W is an out neighbor of V then the
set of terminals you can reach from W
must be disjoint from the set of
terminals you can read from you
otherwise you are in a lot of complexity
theoretic travel as well if you have
this additional condition then you can
do something then you can define
feasible a polytope associated with this
combinatorial complex combinatorial
structure you can define a polytope
which lives in the space of all the
nodes and you can come up with an
extended formulation for that polytope
and this model you can use for example
two
reproduce the destructive programming
case also to reproduce the the dynamic
programming case and in principle you
could do more but I don't have patience
for what you could do in principle more
but I I'd like to tell you what you
could do more in principle so for this
for the dynamic programming situation
the only situation we can handle this
way with with what we had on the
previous slides is the situation where
every state of a dynamic program in
every state every state of a dynamic
program is computed of course from its
predecessor states but in a trivial way
by enumerating all kind of possibilities
somehow of the outcome of the essential
previous States now if you might might
have some dynamic programming algorithms
where you compute two state where you
compute the current state as the outcome
of a more complex
implicit combinatorial optimization
problem in the outcomes of the previous
States you might think of something like
this if you have something like this
then this framework would cover this as
well so whenever you are in the
situation that you have a dynamic
programming algorithm of this weird kind
and you would like to come up with an
extended formulation from that you might
want to use this branch polyhedra branch
combinatorial systems okay but let's
leave it at this level of detail for the
moment because I more I really want to
go a little bit more into these
especially these techniques of dual
ization and of applying redundant
information so first of all let's talk
about this realization technique which
goes back as I said to Martin a late 80s
published early 90s and this is roughly
based on this following observation so
the extension complexity of a polytope
described in this way so as ax less than
or equal to beta times the all one
vector so all the right hand sides are
beta this is important for this approach
all the right-hand side are the same
beta the extension complexity of such a
polytope polyhedron is bounded from
above by the extension complexity of the
convex hull of the rows of a last one
why is this let's see why this is this
the reason for this inequality is just a
pedo ality let's write it down well we
want to characterize when we have ax
less than or equal to beta times the old
one vector and well of course this ax
less than or equal to beta times the one
vector is equivalent to the maximum the
maximum of 80 X where a runs through all
convex combinations of these
inequalities is less than equal to beta
all right this is this is trivial now if
you have an extended formulation for the
convex hull of the rows like this so
this is the extension it's described by
C be less than or equal to D this
inequality system and this is the
projection B is the projection matrix
the matrix that makes the linear map
suppose you have an extended formulation
of the convex some of the rows of a like
this then you can rewrite this as well
you just replace the condition a is in
the convex hull by replacing a by B B
and you end up with with this here XT be
times B condition is C be less than or
equal to D and this is equivalent to
what we would characterize for this X
and now by LP duality the maximum of
this linear program is less or equal to
beta if and only if there is dual
variables Y associated with the
inequalities in this extended
formulation of the convex hull of the
rows of a so if there is dual variables
that proof that the maximum is less than
or equal to beta so you will variable to
satisfy this equation and this condition
on the relation of the dual to the
claimed upper bound
so what we have in this extended
formulation is we have the variables Y
which are associated with the roles of
this extended formulation of the convex
hull of the rows of a and we have this
one inequality that relates this is this
plus one that relates the primal entity
will value the primal well the dual the
dual value and the bound on the primal
that I would like to establish so this
is a simple observation it's just a
pedro ality and now how can you make use
of this well let's make use of this at
the example of the spanning tree poly
tope this is exactly what Martin did in
his paper so you know that the spanning
tree polytope is described like this
roughly you have this ranked
inequalities X of e of you less or equal
to u minus 1 for all
node subsets let's say we talk about
well let's let's talk about arbitrary
graphs so this is even even more more
general context of course in the context
of networks but this is certainly the
spanning people it hope you know this
from Edmunds work and now let's rewrite
this condition slightly so X of EU less
than or equal to u minus 1 we can write
in a more complicated way so this is a
characteristic the incidence vector of
the note said you this is the
characteristic vector of the edge set yi
of you well I call it f well this is
because I now even impose the
inequalities for every subset F of e of
you the inequalities are weaker than but
it will be advantageous soon so this is
trust characteristic vector of notes at
you this is correct with the
characteristic vector of edge set F F
must be some edge set that has n nodes
only in U and now if I multiply it with
this vector the minus 1 vector in the
node space depended the X vector in the
X space then that should be less or
equal to minus 1 this is exactly this
inequality if I write F if I choose F
equals G of U you see this
just a rewriting of the of the
inequality in a more complex way and now
I observe that well if I choose
arbitrary subsets of F of G of U rather
than the entire year view which would be
exactly the translation of this
inequality then the inequalities remain
valid because the left-hand side only
gets smaller so this certainly is
equivalent and now let's investigate
this condition here so let's write down
all these inequalities and let's treat
this with the theory of the previous
slide so beta now is minus 1 so what we
are now interested in is the convex hull
of the rows of this matrix a so the
convex hull of these pairs of
characteristic vectors so pairs of
characteristic vectors of what subset of
nodes and subsets of edges inside that
node set but not all of them not all of
them because
we have this condition we have the
condition only for the non-empty note
set for the empty set you the condition
is not true right we have a minus one
here and nothing can be less than minus
one minus one is smaller than zero right
I mean no one non-negative variables can
sum up to something which is less than
zero right so the inequality is not
valid for you being the empty set so in
the convex hull we have to exclude the
empty set and this is a pity as it turns
out so we call this the non-empty sub
graph polytope so it's a convex hull of
the pairs of characteristic vectors of
subsets you of the notes non-empty
subsets you and characteristic vectors
of arbitrary subsets of edges running
inside this chosen set you now let's see
how we can describe the non-empty sub
graph polytope because due to what we
had on the previous slide we know that
the extended extension of xyg of the
spending people ito up is at most the
extended complexity of this money empty
sub graph polytope plus e plus 1 this is
the other constraint that we have here
the non negativity constraints on the on
the edge variables and then this plus
one from the previous line so let's see
how we can describe the non empty sub
graph but at all and here is the easy
part
so describing the all sub graphs
polytope so if we include also the empty
set is very easy you just write down
these inequalities so the edge variable
each edge variable is bounded from above
by both of its corresponding node
variables that's all why well because
this is a tu system every row has a 1
and a minus 1 so we are done and if it's
a tu system this is integral and it's
easy to see that this is exactly what
you want to have but now we have the
empty set included now we have to get
rid of the empty set unfortunately right
because this is a very very small X
formulation it is just of roughly of
size number of the edges class well plus
the number of nodes or something well of
number of edges roughly it's a linear
size description but we have to get rid
of the of the empty set and the only way
we know how to do is we just enumerate
over every vertex prescribe it to be
in the set so we go to the face one
after the other for each node 3 we go to
the face of this one defined by Z V
equals 1 we take the convicts all by
lash the Union and we are done
at the cost of well a factor of number
of nodes so now this description is
number of nodes times number of edges
and that's how it is but at least we
have this so we find that the extension
complexity is bounded from above by
number of nodes times number of edges so
edges and nodes in some constants and so
on so this is what Martin did now what
we were together did together was
Micaela called forty and two of my
former PhD student Stefan Varrick and
Mattias Vita we investigated what is a
description of the non empty sub graph
poly tope in the original space and it
turns out also this is just as I said
what not improved sorry it turns out
that you can describe the non empty sub
graph poly tope in the original space by
the inequalities of course that we have
for the all sub graph for the top and
one inequality for each spanning tree
okay you can do this but now we are in a
pretty nice situation because again
going back to margins observation from
the beginning so the extended objects eg
of the non empty sub graph poly tope
roughly is bounded from above by the
extension complexity of the spanning
tree poly tope the convex hull of the
connection of the rows of this matrix so
what we see is that the extension up
laxity of the non-empty sub graph
polytope and the spanning tree polytope
is roughly the same so here it is
written down this is the arrow between
the two so it's roughly the same and
this can be exploited by a very very
nice observation due to stem and and
three co-authors costea tony hone and
surely because if you have a graph of
genus G let's say bounded genus Mable
maybe then it is well known that you
find square root of G times number of
nodes in the graph many nodes
after hulls removal the graph is planar
now you can describe the non empty sub
graph polytope by enumerating over all
these removal nodes and the planar thing
that remains if none of the guys is in
the set u so again by balázs you obtain
an extended formulation of the non-empty
sub graph poly tope roughly of that
number times what you need in order to
describe what you need in order to
describe the the all sub graph polytope
and what you need in order to describe
the non-empty sub graph poly tope of a
planar graph but we haven't seen
anything about the planar graph but in
the next chapter we will see how to
describe the spanning tree poly tope of
a planar graph by linear size extended
formulations extended formulation thus
by the relation of the previous slide
the extended extension up laxity of the
non-empty sub graph poly tope of a
planar graph as well as of linear size
so putting together all this you find
that the extended extension complexity
of the spanning tree poly tope and also
of the non-empty sub graph poly tope of
a graph of genus tree is bounded from
above by square root 3 times e times
square root of number of nodes so in
particular if G is a constant it's just
e times square root of V and not e times
V as we had from Martins formulation in
the general setting ok so let's go to
the probably last chapter I can I can
treat the chapter on redundant
information I think we will have to
reflect we have to skip the leave out
the reflections but as I said they are
not so applicable in too many situations
anyway so let's talk about this last
really important as I find construction
mechanism which I call redundant
information so what do I mean by this by
this I mean the approach of adding some
variables that reflect some
combinatorial information about the
solutions that is redundant because it
is it is they are already in the
original formulation
but which cannot be expressed in a
linear way in the original data so
adding some variables in order to be
able to express some structural
relations between the data which is
nonlinear and I will give basically I
think two examples to you one is a very
classical one it's a very beautiful one
due to Williams from 2001 and it's about
spanning trees and planar graphs so how
can we describe spanning trees in planar
graphs so what as I said we will add
some comment at Oriel information and we
will in fact at a lot of combinatorial
information in this case what do we do
so here's a planar graph and once it is
embedded you know there is a dual graph
like this one now from basic graph
theory you know that every Spain uh tree
in the primal graph has a property that
its complement I mean the edges of the
dual graph corresponding to its
complement form a spanning tree in the
dual graph this is basic most basic
graph theory so what we do now is we
consider both not only the primal trees
but also but pair them with their dual
trees which is completely redundant
information you can of course come up
with this but it's not a linear relation
and we even add more information we
distinguish both a primal and the dual
root there is a technical condition that
the primary root should be on the face
corresponding to the dual root which is
just technical don't care about this and
now this pair of spanning trees we even
direct make directed our bora senses out
of these spanning trees so we even add
more redundant information so we look at
spares of pairs of four senses in this
sense and clearly this is a lot of
information and it's pretty easy to
understand that once you can describe
all these vectors associated with these
structures you can project this down to
the spanning tree polytop we will have
to project you later on the slide but
now we try to I think later on the on
the slide yes now we try to describe the
polytope which i call PR
of all these pairs of abhorrent senses
and it turns out this is very easy to
describe here it is how it goes for
every original primal edge VW we now
have four arcs to primal arcs and to do
larks and you associated associate Y
variables with the primal and D
variables with the dual arms and now we
write down those conditions that come to
our minds in the first minute of
thinking about this problem first
condition says out of these four arts
exactly one must be taken second
condition is this is our Borah senses so
unless one of the guys is routes the
outgoing arcs should sum up to one and
this is the second condition to two
primal and condition to duel and then we
have non negativity this is already
there we don't even have to think about
this then we observe that this is a tu
system and then we only have to argue a
bit combinatorially to find that indeed
the zero one solutions to this system
are exactly our pairs this is not too
hard slightly it's a few lines of our
knee so if a very nice extended
formulation and how did it work you
associated more form of information to
your to your to your vectors to your
comm unit or structure and in this case
you were lucky enough to end up with
extended representing vectors whose
convex hull you can easily describe this
is the ideal situation this is not
always the case for example you can also
interpret in a similar way the spanning
tree formulation of Martin we didn't see
the variables explicitly here but you
can interpret the variables that come up
in the following way so again you look
at the by directed version of your graph
and now for each node you spend a set of
variables associated with the arcs in
the by directed version so let's say
each node has a color so now you have n
coloured sets of variables so to speak
and now for every colors of every note
you write down the trivial condition
that you have on the Borah senses with
that route and the trivial condition is
just this out degree condition here you
write it down for every of the of the
notes for every of the color for every
color class of variables you write it
down and then you write down what is a
projection and write on that the X
variables associated with let's say an
edge is just for each route it is the
sum of the two arc variables
corresponding to the Morrisons with that
route and that you write down for each
route in your graph this way you bind
bind you you you you bind the different
Borah senses together because you write
on the projection must be equal to the
sum of these two these two variables for
each route so implicitly also bind these
two ybarra senses together and this is
the extended formation that works for
the spanning tree polytope but what you
end up with is not the convex hull of
the characteristic vectors of these
extenders of these amorous senses you
end up with something that works but
it's not the convex R that's more
complicated okay but also they are in
this interpretation you add additional
information namely how does it look if I
direct everything to if I look at the
different appearances that correspond to
my spanning tree how does it look here
at this information and you write down
the conditions that you derive from that
and this is good enough for you okay the
same trick this is about some
computation experiments we did some
years ago with with the planar
formulation by Williams of course we did
not compute spanning trees minimum
spanning trees with that formulation
that does that not fun but what we did
is we looked at degree bounded spanning
trees with that formulation and compared
it to the from a formulation where we
when we separated the ranking equalities
and so on and here you see some speed
ups it's just meant in order to impress
you of the practical value of extended
formulations in particularly for this
planar spanning tree formulation of of
waves but what I would like to use the
remm
very few minutes for is to talk about
something that I very recently did
together with a PhD student of mine
million reason and this is about well
polynomials spanning-tree optimization
so what what is this about so suppose
you want to solve minimize let's say a
polynomial in the hedge variables over
the spanning trees of the polytope of
the graph you have a tenth suppose you
want to do this and let's say this
script M is the set of monomials in your
polynomial so it's identified among our
meal with a subset of edges the edges
correspond to the variables right now in
order to do it within the optimization
we look at these extended vectors so X
is an incidence vector of a spanning
tree and we have a y Y variable for each
of the monomials and this is just meant
to be an indicator indicating whether
all the variables in that monomial are
in the spanning tree that we are
considering so indicating whether the
monomial evaluates to one or not now we
would love to have the convex all of
these extended vectors because as soon
as we can describe the convex all of
these vectors we can do linear
optimization over these extended sets
and so we can do polynomial optimization
over at least with polynomials where the
set of monomials is in in that in that
script M usually you will not be able to
do this of course you will not be able
to cut describe the convex hull here
completely but what you can hope for is
that for maybe four single monomials
here you can maybe describe the convex
hull there is no complexity theoretic
argument against it for a single
monomial is very easy to solve the
optimization problem because there's not
too many cases you have to consider so
for example for single monomial to make
my D eight might be able to describe the
convex hull and then you might be able
to use the description or extended
formulations for these descriptions of
the individual polytope that arise by
adding a single indicator variable
you might just plug together for all the
monomials that you have these
descriptions and hope that you end up
with it with a good
relaxation so this is what is written
down here in the formal way I don't want
to go into detail too much here just
indicate to you what we can do so of
course you can do this destructively for
such a set of monomials and what is
pretty easy to see is as long as the set
of monomials is a set of subsets suppose
it as long as this process has a
constant width well then you can come up
with an extended formulation of
polynomial size in fact you can come up
with an extended formulation of size
number of nodes to the width of M times
the extension of the exit of the
spending P polytope and this is just you
two
there were theorem you decompose your
your your your set of monomials your
posted into into chains as many you need
as many as width of M is well worth and
now you enumerate over all possibilities
where in each chain the first edge is
not in the solution so it's an easy
enumeration argument but it's a huge
number usually here so let's see what
whether we can do better for example if
we have just one chain and the case of
one chain implicit or not is is a
special case of what has been done by
official official McCormack last year
even in the general case of Metroid's
and in the same setting in our setting
where on the previous slide what they
can do is they can describe for a single
chain for a single chain of monomials
they can give a complete description of
this indicator polytope it involves the
McCormick's inequalities not this my
comic but the the order my comic
inequalities and some modified Rankin
equalities here but it's a huge
description of course you need for all
the subsets here or or kind of subsets
that you plug together you need an
inequality and the question is whether
we can do something with extended
formulations here we can do before just
indicating to you that we can do
something let me mention that this study
these studies were initiated by crime
and client and fish and fish are
initiated by blue heron client and they
treated the case of a single pair of
edges of so just the product of two edge
for the spanning tree and what we can do
is we can come up with an extended
formulation which let me briefly go back
instead of having this size so v2 the
well the we - the width of em now we
have a single chain so V times number so
extent V times extension complexity of
the spanning tree poly tope we can come
up with an extended formulation which
has extended from an extension
complexity of the span if you pull it up
plus in this case mm bar let's say this
is V this is the size of the largest
monomial times e so instead of
multiplying this by the number of nodes
we have just plus V times e here and
this we do by using the variables that I
indicated to you that you would have in
the Marten formulation we use these
variables and find that they pretty much
have to do with the product variable so
with a variable let's say Y that
indicates whether the entire set of the
monomial is in the tree that we are
considering they very much have to do
with these variables at least in the
special case that our chain of monomials
is in fact a chain of trees so we need
that it's a chain of trees it's not
allowed to be disconnected this is
special situation we can also deal with
with a disconnected case at least in
case we have a product of two variables
also for this we can come up with a very
small extended formulation by means of
these additional variables they have a
combinatorial meaning and the last thing
I just want to mention to you is now
what you would like to do if you can
describe the indicator polytopes for a
pair of variables or a pair of adjacent
variables in the situation it's it's
easier what you would like to do is you
would like to do this also of course as
I said if you have several pairs of
variables so not only one monomial but
many many monomials in your let's say
quadratic polynomial now so for example
you might have the product of these
two edges and the product of these two
edges now our extended formulation which
I did not present to you our extended
formulation for this product would use
these Martin variables indicating the de
Boer census and for this product as well
now what you observe is that you can use
the same extension variables the same
variables or the importance is if you
look at this extension at this
relaxation coming from that product and
if you look at the the relaxation coming
from this product this you realize and
if you realize this and only introduce
one set of abour essence variables for
each note but not different sets for
each product then you strengthen the
extension and this yields a provably
tighter relaxation then by just
intersecting the the polytopes the
indicator polytopes for this single
product and this single product so this
is just meant to be an example where you
see that using extended formulations for
this individual indicator program
polytopes using extended formulations
and identifying some relations in the
extension variables can provably
strengthen your relaxation over working
in the original space by describing the
individual polytopes ok so this is the
this is why I like so much this idea of
combinatorial information because this
combinatorial information that you have
in mind so specific pre images of your
vertices of the polity of you're
interested in the extension that you can
use in order to identify these relations
and you know not to go too much over
time I'd stop here and thanks for your
attention
a little lower time I think we'll take
questions we meet again